I love that you're writing things down
dude and you have follow-up questions
and it's like yeah it's uh I don't know
I'm trying to make sure we have to
talk about so what you you're coming in
dude
prepared very because I've been very
unprepared for the last
year or so that we've been trying to do
this yeah yeah so I'm trying to what's
the switch what's the switch I don't
know I I think I said while we were on
the road last time last week that I'm
finding myself the most driven I've ever
been in my career because I've for the
first time really enjoying what I'm
doing yeah like purpose is what we
talked about last week yeah right which
part are you enjoying the whole thing
just it's something different I was
doing the same thing for so long yeah
you know and I think having a nice
change of pace and seeing a different
side of the world that I was still
living in probably like that I was
working in right because I was working
in TV production and stuff like that so
I was working behind the camera the post
was in in front of it so it I'm not on
TV sets or anything like that but I'm
still on that other side yeah right and
it's not something I ever thought I'd
really enjoy or want to pursue because
of how scared I am or was of standing in
front of people or trying to be myself
or anything like that so I I think now
that I'm discovering
a new fond uh
purpose yeah that is it's giving me a
different sense of Drive the good thing
about this job
is that
it is different every time you do it not
just a podcast job but you know being on
stage and a lot doing live things that
variable of not not
it never get being perfect because it's
live and who knows what's going to
happen and maybe I'm the wild card is
the other people
right you know what I mean and so I I
that's what I really love about it
[Music]
bring it
I like to smoke weed
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm